y aunque el duelo entre yo by de nito
nation está absorbiendo toda la atención
no es sólo la presidencia la que está en
juego en eeuu los votantes también
designan a otros miles de cargos desde
senadores hasta sheriff y legisladores
locales en cuanto a los 435 escaños de
la cámara de representantes los
resultados parciales sugieren una
ventaja para los demócratas se
presentaron a las elecciones de esta
semana con grandes esperanzas de
aumentar su control mayoritario de la
cámara pero el partido sufre hasta el
momento la pérdida de cerca de seis
escaños
además distritos como iowa incluso una
parte de california que los demócratas
habían recuperado en 2018 no
permanecieron azules we don't know when
pero no ganamos todas las batallas pero
ganamos la guerra los estadounidenses
también fueron llamados el martes para
renovar un tercio del senado por una
parte los republicanos conquistaron
estados clave pero no han conseguido los
escaños necesarios para declarar que
ostentan la mayoría las esperanzas
demócratas ahora descansan en georgia
este estado podría en efecto definir la
inclinación del senado
la carrera parece encaminarse a una
segunda vuelta
espero que el resultado de las
elecciones sea positivo porque todos nos
llevamos bien realmente ambos partidos
se llevan bien espero realmente espero
que los asientos en el senado sigan
siendo los mismos para que puedan
aprender a llevarse bien
los estadounidenses tendrán que ser
pacientes para saber los resultados
finales ya que ante este contexto en
algunos casos no se resolverá sino hasta
el próximo año y ahora el riesgo es que
el próximo presidente se quede sin una
mayoría clara en el senado y la cámara